the relative frequency table below shows
statistics from a study about the
relationship between the amount of time
a person spends using a computer before
bed and the amount that a person sleeps
each night for computer use each
participant was classified as minimal
moderate or extreme so let's look at the
frequency table below so let's see
that's the frequency table and let's see
there's three categories of computer
time just like they told us minimal
moderate and extreme this is before they
go to bed or at night and then they have
the three categories of how much they're
sleeping five or few hours per night
five to seven hours per night or seven
or more hours okay so that's fair enough
so let's see what they want us to do so
they tell us suppose there were 17
people in the study who were both in
moderate computer users and got five to
seven hours of sleep so moderate five to
seven so this category right over here
there were 17 people in this category
over here and just to mark that let me I
copy and pasted this chart onto my
scratch pad so so I can write on it so
this group they're telling us this group
and my pen is really acting up I don't
understand what's going on this group
right over here there are 17 people so
that group right over there is 17 people
now what are they asking us they're
saying so they're saying how many people
in the study were both extreme computer
users and got 5 to 7 hours of sleep
round to the nearest whole number so
extreme and got 5 to 7 get my scratch
pad out so they're saying how many
people are in how many people are in
this in this bucket in this bucket right
over here I on they have to replace my
pen tablet or something that why it's
getting all splotchy like this so how
would we think about this there's 17
people in this group how many people are
in this group well they tell us that 17
is 34 percent of the row of the row
total so I guess you could say 17 is 34
point three percent of the moderate of
the moderate computer users or you could
say that 17 is thirty percent of the
people who slept five to seven
hours each night or you could say 17 is
10% is 10% of the total of the total
number of people so let's just go with
that we could figure out the total
number of people so 10% just let me
write it this way so 10% 10% of the
total 10% of total is going to be equal
to 17 or that the total just divide both
sides by 10% is equal to 17 divided by
10% which is the same thing as 17 over
0.1 which of course is equal to 170 so
the total is 170 and they tell us that
extreme extreme computer users represent
extreme computer users who sleep 5 to 7
hours per night represent 11.7% 11.7% of
the total so they answer their question
of how many people were extreme computer
users who sleep 5 to 7 hours per night
that's eleven point seven percent of 170
so let's go back over here so we
actually have a little calculator tool
here so it's it's eleven point seven
percent which is zero point one one
seven times 170 times
170 is and let me make sure that you can
see what I'm doing by scrolling over a
little bit x 170 is equal to nineteen
point eight nine so if we're rounding to
the nearest whole that's going to be 20
people 20 people and then they are going
to ask us some questions they say does
the table show evidence of an
association between being a minimal
computer user and getting seven hours of
sleep or more so let's just look at the
chart so an association between being a
minimal computer user and getting seven
hours of sleep or more so it looks like
minimal computer users so that's this
these are the minimal computer users who
get seven or more hours of sleep and
there's a couple of ways to read this so
you could say that fifty-one percent of
men
all computer users get seven or more
hours of sleep you could say that of the
people who get seven or more hours of
sleep 55 percent are minimal computer
users and of course this one just says
that minimal computer users who get
seven or more hours of sleep represent
18.3 percent of all of the people who
were surveyed so let's look at the
choices and when I just actually before
I even look at the choices let's see if
there's an association it does look like
if you look at if you look at minimal
computer users it looks like a small
percentage only 16% get five or few
hours a higher percentage gets five to
seven hours and 51 percent the highest
percentage gets seven or more so it
looks like for minimal computer you for
minimal computer users it looks like the
the distribution is definitely weighted
towards getting more getting more sleep
and actually for example if we look at
the extreme computer users it's the
opposite trend forty per six forty seven
percent have five or few hours per night
33 percent five to seven hours and then
only 19 percent get seven or more and it
looks like the moderate is someplace in
between so just looking at this just
looking at at each of these rows it
looks like there's a trend where you use
less if you use a computer for less time
you're more likely to have more sleep
and likewise if you use a computer more
you're more likely to have less sleep
another way to think about it when you
look at the people who are getting seven
or more hours of sleep a majority of
them a majority of them are minimal
computer users and there's three
categories so for 55% to be minimal
computer users really does feel like the
minimal computer users are are more you
know they're definitely more
disproportionately representing the
people who are getting seven or
disproportionately represented in this
category of seven or more hours of sleep
and you see that the extreme computer
users in this category they represent
only 20% of this category so it does
look like there is an association
between minimal computer use and getting
seven or more hours of sleep but let's
look at the actual choices they give us
does the table show evidence of an
association between a minimal computer
user and getting seven hours of sleep or
more so yes because 35.1%
are extreme computer users and
twenty-nine point one percent of people
are modern
well I go with the yes but this doesn't
seem to really back up the claim this is
just giving us some random data about
the percentage that are extreme computer
users or moderate computer users no well
I already explained why I go with yes
that there's does seem to be a trend and
I don't even believe what the statement
is because the total column percentages
are essentially equal we see that the
total column that the column percentage
is the column percentages are not equal
for the various for for people who are
getting seven hours or more of sleep so
we see that right over here 55 25 2000
with that one either yes because 51% 51%
of minimal computers get seven or more
hours of sleep and only 33% of all
computer users get seven or more hours
yeah I mean that that seems pretty good
fifty-one percent a minimal computer
users get seven or more hours of sleep
and only 33% of all computer users get
seventy get seven or more hours of sleep
so that looks like a pretty good
explanation so I'll check that but let's
just review all of them no well I
already said I think it's yes but
because the total percentage of extreme
users who get five to seven hours of
sleep is the same as a total percentage
of moderate computer users who get five
to seven hours of sleep so that doesn't
it doesn't really be it's not touching
on the point that we're looking for yes
because 55% of people who get 75 who get
seven or more hours of minimal computer
users and only 35% of all people are
minimal computer users actually I'll go
with this as well oh yeah this is this
is a multi-select here so I could select
that one as well so this one we're
looking at of the so here we looked we
looked at the percentage of minimal
computer users who get seven hours of
sleep and we saw that percentage is
higher than for the whole population
here we're looking of we're looking at
the people who get seven or more hours
of sleep and we're saying well 55
percent of them
55 percent of them are minimal computer
50 55 percent of them are minimal
computer users even though only 35
percent of all the people are minimal
computer users so I would go with both
of these and so let us check our answer
and we
it right